a medida que el contraataque ucraniano
se acerca cada vez más a la ocupada
gerson las autoridades rusas han puesto
en marcha el transporte para evacuar a
los civiles diciendo que entre 50 y
60.000 serán evacuados de una parte de
la región en los próximos seis días sin
embargo las autoridades ucranianas ven
en esto una motivación política
[Música]
todos podemos ver que la evacuación en
gersones esencialmente una deportación
su propósito Es crear una especie de
pánico en gerson
si las evacuaciones son Realmente
involuntarias esto constituiría un
crimen de guerra pero los lugareños
escuchan el sonido de los bombardeos en
la línea de combate y temen verse
atrapados en el fuego cruzado
cuando escuchamos que se acercaba el
frente porque escuchamos que los misiles
eran más intensos las bombas que caían
de los aviones decidimos ir todos
a medida que el contraataque ucraniano
se acerca la estrategia abiertamente
declarada
Moscú es destruir la infraestructura
energética un plan ya en marcha las
fuerzas armadas de la federación rusa
continuaron lanzando ataques con
armamento aéreo de largo alcance y alta
precisión contra las instalaciones del
sistema de energía y control militar de
Ucrania todos los objetivos asignados
fueron neutralizados según la admisión
de kiev las fuerzas rusas han destruido
el 30% de las centrales eléctricas del
país en una semana llevando al
presidente a anunciar una suerte de
austeridad energética
por favor no enciende equipos eléctricos
innecesarios limite el uso de aquellos
dispositivos que consumen más energía
la restricciones estarán vigentes en
todo el país de 7 de la mañana a 7 de la
noche a partir del jueves y el uso de
las luces de las calles estará limitado
en algunas ciudades con el invierno a la
vuelta de la esquina
Moscú Espera que esto debilite la
resistencia de Ucrania